au contraire légalisation de
l'euthanasie naulleau allez je vais
mettre sur vous alors sur des sujets
aussi délicats j'hésite toujours un
sourire pour compte quelque chose de
très intime sa touche aux fins dernières
il ya presque pas de sujet plus crucial
plus important néanmoins j'ai été très
touché par une scène d'un film de denys
arcand réalisateur québécois les
invasions barbares où on voit un homme
organisé la cérémonie d'adieu avec ses
amis ils viennent il est encore en bonne
santé il peut parler avec eux ça m'a
beaucoup touché je me dis c'est quand
même mieux que de rester des jours et
des jours et des mois au chevet de
quelqu'un qui est complètement perdue
physiquement mentalement dont on va
garder un souvenir atroce
donc ça m'a touché et je pense qu'on
devrait évoluer vers ça après il ya
beaucoup de évidemment de barrières
qu'il faudrait mettre il faut être sûr
de l'assentiment de la personne il ya le
poids de la religion en france qui
compte beaucoup et qui voit là pas
seulement le catholicisme tous les
monothéismes ont évidemment opposé
assure à cela mais vraiment ce film m'a
fait réfléchir et je trouve qu'il ya
quelque chose de plus digne pour soi et
pour celui qui va mourir
eric revel bah moi je suis pouvoir je le
propos d'eric me va tout à fait au début
il ya des convictions personnelles
j'en ai et et religieusement
c'est une question je me suis souvent
posé pour mes proches mais aussi pour
moi-même
maintenant on voit trop de gens souffrir
il ya trop de souffrance je parle pas de
ceux qui partent mais simplement
demandent à mourir manière respectable
et j'ai longtemps balancé entre mes
convictions chrétiennes et ce choix là
est en fait aujourd'hui je suis au clair
avec moi même c'est à dire que je pense
qu'il faut légaliser l'euthanasie
il faut permettre aux gens qui veulent
partir dans leur pays entourés de leurs
proches ne pas s'exiler comme si le
fuyait un fléau et de pouvoir mourir
dignement de leur pays que s'il vous est
concrètement on aura bernard août oui
moi je suis contre parce que je pense
que je crains un peu l'ouverture
justement avec la légalisation de
l'euthanasie aux dérives
je crains et des rues premièrement
deuxièmement je suis content parce que
je me dis que quelque part on n'a pas
décidé de sa naissance et je trouve que
on n'a pas à décider de sa mort c'est ma
conviction
et puis trois
m et dernier point pour le fait que j'ai
oublié mon 3e voilà en tout cas moi là
moi je suis vraiment intérieurement je
peux revenir un petit peu voilà non mais
j'aurais là je crains les dérives de
l'état nazi de dérive
je trouve que conviés par conviction
personnelle je trouve que c'est bien on
n'a pas décidé de sa naissance on n'est
pas obligé de décider de sa mort et je
vois tout dans toute la sphère vincent
lambert ce que ça donnera donc voilà
pour tout ça moi je suis absolument
contre bernard oui après ces sujets très
délicat blessures on n'a pas décidé de
sa mort moi j'ai vécu avec la fin de vie
dément grand père et je peux vous
garantir que les quatre derniers jours
si j'avais pu j'aurais arrêté sa vie ce
qui me le demandez donc c'est vrai que
choisit pas sa mort mais lui justement
il souffrait tellement qu'il me disait
là il faut arrêter je souffre trop fou
que je vivais j'espère que ce soit le
soin est mort et c'est que notre lundi
quatre fois la diva le matin mais si on
m'avait si j'avais pu appuyer sur le
bouton à 10 ans papy c'est fini je
l'aurais fait voilà donc c'est délicat
comme sujet mais cap didier confronté à
un certain moment quelqu'un qui souffre
et qui ne veut plus vivre c'est pas moi
qui le dit chez moi j'aimais surtout je
dis jamais accroche-toi papy tu veux si
tu vois tu vas y arriver que ces
éléments je chantais même tel désarroi
quel désespoir que je dis j'aime et je
me trouvais un pitch en quoi bien sur
jimmy alors ouais moi je partage l'avis
de christine sur le fait qu'il ya deux
dates que scientifiquement peut pas
déterminer si la naissance et la mort
j'ai accompagné des gens dans la mort
que ce soit aux urgences et des morts
parfois indignes sur un brancard médecin
je médecins et si on pose la question
français souhaitez-vous mourir dans
d'atroces sur france sur un brancard aux
urgences en art en train d'agoniser ou
souhaitez-vous l'euthanasie tout le
monde dira l'euthanasie est ce que tu
décris berna
c'est typiquement le problème qui se
passe en france c'est l'accès aux soins
palliatifs
si on a des gens qui ne souffre pas sont
accompagnés parce que actuellement il
existe qu'on appelle la sédation
profonde c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où c'est qu'un malade un
pronostic vital engagé sur le très court
terme on peut le cdt jusqu'à ce que la
mort arrive c'est différent de
l'euthanasie c'est un accompagnement et
il m'est arrivé de pousser des
médicaments de la morphine pour soulager
les gens et là les gens partent
lorsqu'ils partent dans la dignité sans
souffrance en agoniser eh bien les
choses évoluent et donc à 50 ans quand
vous êtes en pleine forme vous dit tom
et moi j'accepterai pas par exemple de
me lever la nuit pour aller faire pipi
puis à 60 ans vous commencez à pisser
trois fois que la nuit vous êtes un mais
ce serait bien que la journée j'arrive à
me retenir
et puis à 70 ans vous dit bon je fais
pis tu la journée et la nuit mais
j'aimerais bien pouvoir manger et puis
au fur et à mesure vos objectifs recul
c'est à dire que plus vous vieillissez
plus vous accepter certaines choses de
la vie
il ne faut pas dire que les gens qui
sont alités aux urgences ou dans
l'hôpital qui souffrent et qui ne
parlent plus veulent mourir pour autant
il ne faut pas que nous transmettions
notre peur parce que souvent ça la
crainte en disant il faut qu'on s'en
débarrasse et christina très raison là
elle risque la dérive on a eu un
reportage est pas très longtemps je sais
plus qui avait fait sa une dame de 50
ans qu'elle est très bien en pleine
forme et qui dit j'ai tout vécu dans ma
vie je souhaite mourir et je vais aller
en suisse c'est le large petit à petit
on va arriver vers saint nazaire
mercredi j'ai repensé à la dérive g2
l'accès des soins palliatifs en france
permettra de diminuer la question de
l'euthanasie parce que si on accompagne
et qu'on est entouré et qu'on évite les
situations de mort horrible et 1 din en
suffoquant
eh ben on aura peut-être pas besoin de
choisir la date de sa mort alors
qu'arrive vous êtes entre lévis et c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est un sujet
qui touche à l'intimé plus qu'au
collectif de kéhi sujets politiques en
général touche je vais dire le collectif
nous touchent à tous il faut porter des
idées d'intérêt général puisque
d'intérêts particuliers or là c'est un
sujet qui est très particulier qui
touche à l'intimé de chacun
moi je suis contre le suicide je suis
pour la possibilité de moins dans la
dignité
où est la part des choses où est la
frontière c'est compliqué je voudrais
pas qu'on utilise l'euthanasie tel un
suicide mes convictions moisson contre
le suicide est effectivement je suis
beaucoup plus comment dirais-je dans ma
philosophie moi je suis un provincial
orientale je crois au destin des séismes
octobre dès que le mektoub exactement on
a tous un look tout on a tous un destin
on dit c'est écrit là où je crois ces
choses là mais je crois ces choses là
c'est moi ces choses là et j'ai envie
d'assumer que je crois ces choses là le
quai en même temps je ne sais pas si je
me retrouvais dans une situation demain
donc de grande détresse par une
situation de santé de kaki est tout à
fait en péril
comment je réagirais et de comme je ne
le sais pas j'ai pas envie d'avoir un
avis tranché
parce que voilà un moment donné faut
dans la vie faut savoir dire j'hésite
c'est compliqué et c'est un sujet qu'il
est qui est particulièrement complexe
alors il aurait subi le temple lors très
vite je voudrais juste à avoir un mot
effectivement pour les familles comme
l'a dit bernard parce que souvent elles
se retrouvent dans des situations même
deux
voir faire des choix ce comme le disait
jimmy effectivement ils poussent parfois
la morphine donc c'est quelque part un
peu l'euthanasie non soulage des
gentilles informer sur les ailes on sait
bien qu'à l'hôpital
la situation se présente c'est la
réalité parfois le personnel soignant
est amené à prendre des décisions alors
on n'appelle pas ça la nation mais il
met en condition d'ailleurs on vous
prévient la personne va mourir demain ou
après demain mais regarde vers le haut
lambert le bordel est d'accord mais
vincent lambert c'est la loi et laurent
il faut penser au personnel soignant il
faut pouvoir le soulager de ces choix là
et soulager la famine ces choix là parce
que la réalité sur le terrain
c'est que effectivement parfois on est
obligé ils sont obligés d'aller jusqu'à
soulager la personne jusqu'à la mort
c'est tabou mais c'est la réalité et si
on légifère pas plu c'est qu'on donne
pas le choix à chacun et qu'on est
obligé lent parfois à partir en belgique
pour le faire c'est terrible que
l'afrique ne répond pas à center vous
êtes tête vous êtes très forte non le
mot état nazi en fait me gêne je préfère
parler d'accompagnement de fin de vie
chacun a droit à une vie à une fin de
vie digne et l'acharnement thérapeutique
c'est une douleur pour le patient et
c'est aussi une douleur pour les
familles et je pense que si on légalise
c'est à minima pour avoir le choix que
chacun puisse décider de partir à
l'onema vente de noms dont un tout petit
peu plus de dignité parce que ce qui se
passe dans les hôpitaux qui deviennent
parfois des mois c'est un scandale je
vous pour ou contre la légalisation de
l'euthanasie ou pour à 74% contre à 26%
pour à 60 que la société précédente et
prennez et c'est un cas d'école ou les
convictions intimes des individus
restent ballack a influencé les actes
légaux d'intérêt général vous savez
l'avortement dont beaucoup de conviction
c'est proscrit
et pourtant ces permis est organisée par
la loi